Shan was ordered to bow down to us so
whenever we bow down to him and follow
him we're serving an entity that is
lower than ourselves we are lowering
ourselves honestly man the fact that I
became a Muslim is a miracle Subhan
Allah it's a miracle cuz I was one of
those atheists that hated religion I
hated Islam not just Islam I hated Islam
I hated Christianity I thought it was
the source of all the world's problems
one day just why do you believe the
things that you believe and boom six
days later I'm making
Salah welcome back to the real podcast
in the dun the three Muslims but today
we only have two Muslims alhamdulillah
I'm joined here with my brother Dr
Dennis Salam
alikum Salam
brother we're going to be sharing One
mic today so bear with us but
alhamdulillah beautiful brother that I
met in the mjid over here in St Louis
why don't we start off with a little bit
about yourself for the viewers how you
got on Dean anything you want them to
know bro take your
time
uh I was technically born a Muslim but
uh you know just just looking back you
know I grew up in a communist country uh
and really communism was infused in all
aspects of Islam so I don't think
anybody knew what Islam is even though
they call themselves Muslims it was a
more of a cultural experience for most
people than actual Deans and then I
became an atheist and I was an atheist
until I was 30 and um you know just one
day I was just sitting there in my in in
my apartment and a thought came to my
head why do you believe the things that
you believe and uh for some reason I
just kind of turned to to the holy books
and I first read the Bible I actually
first read the Bible and after I was
done reading the Bible I read the Quran
and uh it confirmed the Bible just like
it claimed so I think a lot of people
what they don't know is because they
assume that uh people who call
themselves Christians actually practice
out of the Bible but when you really
look at the Bible there's discrepancy in
it but the the arguments or the verses
that
claim that Prophet uh Isa Prophet Jesus
peace be upon Him is not Divine and not
a son actual Son of God are are just are
there's a preponderance of those and
they're much more direct and much more
clear whereas the verses one could use
to kind of make that argument that is in
mream Christianity are very few and far
in between and very kind of abstract and
not direct like the other verses so uh
once I read the Quran it was it was uh
several you know things that hit me all
at once the the truth of what it was
saying the fact how it knew what every
human being thinks it just knew me and
the first uh if you read Surah bakar
right there at the beginning I found
myself you know it defines three types
of people those who believe and what
they're like those who disbelieve and I
was them you know it says as for those
who disbelieve whether you warn them or
not they will not believe and that's who
I was uh so honestly man uh the fact
that I became a Muslim is a
miracle Subhan Allah it's a miracle
because I was one of those atheists that
hated religion I hated Islam not just
Islam I hated Islam I hated Christianity
I hated Judaism I thought it was the
source of all the world's problems and
you know just like you're that's what
average atheist think I think and I I
actually made concerted effort to uh
learn something a little bit uh enough
from each book so I can make
counterarguments to anybody that try to
talk to me about Dean and I did that for
years and years and years I did that and
uh then one day just why do you believe
the things that you believe and boom six
days later I'm making
s and and tell us tell tell them a
little bit about what we were talking
about over dinner how you know there was
a time where you know you started taking
your life a little bit more seriously
you went to school tell us about that
and how your experience a lot of people
don't understand science so some people
think that science is above God and it's
something that's almost
unscientific yeah I I think uh a lot of
people's approach to science is actually
Faith because they either don't know how
to read the research papers or even if
they knew know how to read research
papers and the statistics uh they don't
know how to evaluate methodology so what
they are doing is depending on the
scientists to tell them what is right
from wrong and if you are actually once
you gain the ability to evaluate all
those things you realize there's still a
lot of conjecture in there that is
pretending to be science science should
be facts things that are reproducible or
directly observable right uh a lot of
what people claim to be science isn't it
as a matter of fact I just uh uh saw an
article today that over 10,000 medical
journal uh articles that were published
in a peerreview uh Journal were now
redacted what does that mean for the uh
so what that means is what claimed to be
scientific proof turned out to be lies
and inadequate methodology and all that
so you know people publish science like
this as if it is science and a lot of
people that actually publish it your
teachers and all those things they're
just getting it from somewhere else so
uh I think I sent you a video from Dr
James tour which I recommend everybody
take a look at and you know he explains
it a lot better than I do but that is
essentially what it is uh a lot of what
is claimed to be science is actually
Faith yeah it's it's it's their
Dean see I watched that video that you
sent me and I'm going to put it in like
the link in the description to that it
was like the origin of life from James T
and when I watched that towards the end
when he's talking about you know the
interactomes of the cell and how
everything is so fine-tuned the the he
he said this one thing at the end which
caught my eye was it takes more faith to
believe that everything was created by
chance and random error than to just
believe in a Creator and he said I don't
have that much Faith Subhan Allah it's a
little bit ironic to The Atheist you
know it's like a saap in the face um so
have you noticed you know after I guess
going to med school and practicing that
it affected your faith in any chance
because many of the things that I've
taken in stem classes they almost come
from an atheistic lens a lot of these
especially the evolutionary biology
classes
uh I I don't think any of it affected my
faith other than increased it so I've uh
the more I understood about cellular
biology the more I stood understood
about medicine the more I understood how
cells interact I mean it is a it is when
you really think about it look this this
is who we are we are made from Nanobots
which we call cells that are made from
dirt and I mean we're literally they're
literally made from dirt because when
your mother is pregnant what she's
eating is either what grows right out of
the dirt vegetables fruits or is eating
animals that eat things that grow out of
the dirt so it's just processed dirt so
these Nanobots that are just processed
dirt all of a sudden come together and
operate independently on their own like
90% of your bodily functions you don't
control right none of us control so
we're just sitting here steering the
wheel and putting gas in a car and this
this this vehicle is carrying our
conscious and then when you look at it
on a imagine if you could see a body on
a cellular level I mean just like in a
matrix right if you could have that I
don't know if you're if you're old
enough to remember the movie Matrix but
if you kind of could see a body in that
sense what you would see is millions of
Nanobots talking to each other and and
doing a specific function like like a
society there it's like literally a
society you know everybody's got their
job that they have to do and uh as long
as everybody does their job we live and
as soon
as they stop doing their job so what we
call Cancer all that is is immature
cells that do not contribute to society
and they just consume energy and when
you really think about it when we stop
obeying Allah when we do other than what
Allah wants us to do what we are doing
is we are becoming a cancer to our
society because inevitably all these
behaviors are destruction W right CU
when you become liar and everybody else
becomes a liar there's no unit among the
people and it's destruction if you uh
become greedy you're destroying your own
Community everything Allah made Haram
drugs who who destroys Community look at
uh you know uh Kensington Avenue for
example in Philadelphia one of the
biggest drug Avenues but you can go to
any Downtown City and see people who are
addicted they're sick I understand that
but what they're also doing is number
one they're destroying their parents
they're destroying their family and then
they're destroying their Community by
going around and stealing and begging
and all that right they're just
consuming resources and that is what
cancer is I mean it's like and and
there's this one thing that we know as
the prophet mentioned you know you know
all of my um will be forgiven on that
day except those that do their sins
openly and publicly so we know that
there's a difference between just
sitting in private smoking a joint no
one's watching obviously we don't
condone that but those that are
glorifying it those that are making rap
videos those that are promoting this
culture unfortunately there's a lot of
Muslims today right so yeah you know
hijab is sensitive topic but a woman
that is not incorrect hijab and everyone
knows she's Muslim she's doing more harm
to the name of Islam and the reputation
of the um than somebody that's let's say
in private if a man is let's say smoking
I don't know just crack cocaine and he's
doing it in public it's way worse them
knowing they're Muslim and it creates
more of a compound effect a domino
effect cuz I guarantee you bro most
people if they just live a normal clean
life away from Haram they wouldn't
indulge in it but we only do these
things or get caught up in these things
because we saw other people doing these
things what do you think about
that uh yeah I mean when you look at
society and if you look at development
of society and even if you look at your
own youth at a certain age all people
want to do is fit in right and then
because all all people want to do is fit
in you have these traps waiting for you
all over the place I mean just looking
at addiction for example every addict
has a
same entry way into addiction and as
just trying a drug so when uh when I
give Addiction Counseling to people I
say look your environment matters and
how you uh your your your personality
also matters so uh kids with depression
and they don't have any friends when
they make friends who offer them drugs
they will take those drugs because they
want to have friends it is that's how
things work so but once you do that then
you get all that harm that that you know
affects all of us so
I I do think that we also have to
consider like you say you know sinning
in private and all that that that's all
fine and dandy but I really believe that
uh difference between neak and and
actual Islam is effort if you don't have
effort you can call yourself whatever
you want and I think that's we we uh we
have failed significantly by taking an
approach and not talking about this
because look think Navy SEALS or the
British SAS right elite units right what
happens when you say well you don't have
to train you can be 300 lb and you can
still be an a seal what happens when you
say you don't have to make any effort to
become an a seal right but what happens
you will still have the name Navy Seals
but they won't be Navy Seals anymore
right that's the same thing with
Islam if you don't try you can call you
can call yourself a Muslim but we are
supposed to be the elite right a people
people who act like Allah wants them to
act so if we just say you can do
whatever you want and still be this
that's all all we have left is the name
now like you said we're not perfect I'm
not perfect you're not perfect we all
have our problems but it's the effort I
I really think it's the effort that
really tells the difference so this
being said today you know specializing
in you know helping doing addictions
counseling and Research into that a lot
of Muslims are wondering this you know
why are you guys even talking about
addictions you know we're Muslim we
don't we're not caught up in itions
where Muslims are not drinking Muslims
are not smoking Muslims are not watching
you know Haram on their screens so
there's a lot of taboo around these
topics and I feel like when there's
taboo there's a lack of knowledge and
when there's a lack of knowledge we
don't have a way to form these defenses
and these walls to kind of I guess stay
away from shaan and protect ourselves so
what is the reality bro of Muslims and
the addictions that we're caught up
in if you you can you don't have to just
look out it here in the west you can
look even at Arab word world uh for them
captagon which is basically amphetamines
is a big thing you can look uh there's a
documentary that you can look on up on
Afghanistan uh heroin was a big thing
there and and so look Allah is not going
to send a messenger to talk about things
that we're not going to face right so if
we uh look at in the fifth chapter of
Quran verses 90 through 93 this is like
a warning the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him gives to people you know says
uh all you who believe in toxicant and
gambling and altar set up and uh divined
by arrows which is essentially raffling
is what they used to do is they used to
ra Loud Meat with arrows our filth
devil's work avoid them that you may be
successful right I mean again go look go
find a crackhead go find a junkie and
tell me if they're successful right so
this a prophet from God a message from
Allah is coming to us for this right and
then then he tells us why the Shayan is
trying to introduce hatred and animos it
among you by means of intoxicant and
gambling and to keep you away from Salah
to keep you away from prayer and to
cause you to forget about God will you
not then stop look this is like Pro
Prophet Muhammad is talking to people
bro peace be upon him he's talking to
people he says Hey guys you're not going
to stop and the scariest uh verse this
ends uh this is a three verse block and
it says and obey God and obey the
messenger but be warned if you turn away
then on our messenger was only to
clearly
deliver and it's like I do counseling
and the hardest part of counseling is
explaining the gravity of the situation
if if you are about to drive off of a
cliff I can show you there's a cliff you
can look down and you can see oh boy you
can understand but I think we had this
conversation is how can I explain pain
to you if you never felt pain how can I
make you afraid of
it I can't and and that's that's the
issue so if you're not going to listen
to Allah as a Muslim you're probably not
goingon to listen to me and just here in
St Louis uh there have been at least a
dozen Muslims that have died over those
drugs and I get calls almost every week
about other Muslims whose parents are in
the masjids and and they're Believers
and all that and their kids are on drugs
too so if you're especially out here in
the west the traps are everywhere
including the medical community I told
you C cagon is uh a issue you can just
go and Google it yourself and it's an
issue in the Middle East and here we
just called ad
all so to to assume that a stimulant of
like that which provides exactly the
same experience will not affect you in
any way just because from a
doctor is foolish because this it's a
trick of the shaan bro and and and
listen being in in in Western Medical
School have you noticed that kids are
just doing a recreationally like candy
in the name of focus and attention
during
exams absolutely the most abused drug in
on us college campuses is Aderall and
believe it or not I used to be
prescribed Aderall because all I went
and I told the the doctor and it was a
Muslim doctor a Muslim doctor from
Pakistan and I went and I told him look
when I read a book and and listen when I
say this I want you to tell me if you
ever experienced this when I read a book
I I read a page and then I have to
reread it because I realized I was
thinking about something else that's
human that's human and he diagnosed me
with a
disease ADHD so I got to experience that
life for a while yeah I took Aderall
legally and I realized holy smokes man
this is this is a stimulant this is a
ABS this is drugs it changes your
personality it like all drugs on the
front end you know fact fact of the
matter is the reason people get addicted
is on the front ED drug end drugs make
you feel good now what is feeling good
well some people like the energy
experience some people like the downers
you know they like the benzos they like
the heroin they like the weed you know
some people like alcohol because it
takes away the anxiety I don't care it's
not the substance it is what it does for
you if you like what it does for you you
will get addicted and that's the it's
the desire for something I like that's
why we have favorite food favorite food
is essentially an addiction well food
itself can be an addiction when you look
at the prop uh proportions of obesity in
the United States of America you're
doing something that you're consuming
something that is you see it's harmful
to you and you just keep doing it Subhan
Allah and bro this being said you know
when I was in college in University
there's so many brothers that were doing
Aderall uh Xanax just they're just
abusing these things just this party
culture almost in the guise of higher
education you know and this is not a
knock on education but if you're going
to go to school to study are you going
to school to study or you going to do
drugs and just Zena and all this and
listen we know the reality bro many of
our brothers are caught up in that but
change has to begin somewhere so if we
continue letting people just be heedless
and in temporary delusion like we were
talking about and we don't talk about
these issues then there's not going to
be change now we don't care if this
video doesn't you know hit a million
people's hearts but as long as somebody
watching this if it resonates with you
and you can make change do it whether
that is going to be on a personal scale
like leaving these things for the sake
of Allah trying to get help trying to
reach out and see if you can overcome
these addictions whether it can be
helping your mom or your dad or your
brother or your sister or your spouse
somebody that's addicted to these things
because it's a silent killer it's
something that people see the greatest
problem is not knowing you have a
problem and many of these junkies and
these addicts when I talk to them now
and I counsel them they always say oh
bro it's not an addiction because I
could quit anytime I want to I could
stop even tomorrow if I want to okay
then it's like why don't you oh I just
don't choose to yet I'm I'm not addicted
yet but you can't even go a week without
it if you have withdrawal from anything
you're addicted
obviously it's good to be addicted and
and and love to do things that are
beneficial for you right like if I don't
pray uh on time I feel some type of way
which is good right but in the same way
if you are not doing something like
watching Haram and you can't for a week
straight you're addicted to it
unfortunately and we can't just remove
things from our life we got to replace
them with something better so what are
your top before we talk about you know
pornography and stuff like that with
just addictions in general we know we
identifi you know that it is is existing
unfortunately many people are uh
negligent in in this how do we now
overcome these things let's say you have
somebody that's been I guess having you
know alcohol for the 10 years somebody
smokes marijuana every time they come
home every day for 5 years it's a part
of their habit it's a part of their
routine what can they do now and even
before that why should they quit you
know so that that's a good question is
why why should they quit and I think
everybody that comes to a certain point
in addiction realizes why they should
quit right so number one it doesn't
matter what drug even with weed even
with with just marijuana man uh it
changes your personality you start
avoiding your family you you get lazy
you can have bad trips uh you can you
know so uh alcohol alcohol for example
is the worst as far as social
consequences right the fights and the
all that meth I mean go ahead and and
and so start you know taking higher
higher doses of adol pretty soon you
know you're going to start to experience
paranoia and I've actually had several
people who basically developed
schizophrenia I meaning you know they're
hearing things they're paranoid all that
from adero I mean all these things it
may not happen to everyone but look left
and right because you know it's going to
happen to some people and if you're one
of them there's a problem and not to cut
you up bro but just something caught my
mind working in your as an ER doctor
have you noticed Muslims being rushed in
from overdoses and stuff like that
the area where I work at there isn't a
lot of Muslims but uh yeah that's that's
a large majority of the patients we see
so it's not not only uh so what's
happening now is the opioid epidemic is
actually ramping down so overdoses on
fenil and all that a lot of those people
died I mean 880,000 last year somewhere
in range of 80,000 in the United States
of America last year right uh so what is
happening now is meth and and stimulants
it's a stimulant epidemic uh so
unfortunately I think to a large part
the medical industry is uh driving it
like it drove the opio epidemic so if
you don't mind I can give a like a
really short history of how medical
industry me being a doctor how is
destroying people because Shayan is
sitting at every door Shayan isn't just
in the bar he's also in the medical
office bro so listen a big a large
reason why uh opioid epidemic started is
uh because of the medical industry and
there's actually I think a Netflix uh
like a series on that I forgot what it's
called but there is and so what they did
is they misrepresented an an opioid as
non-addictive and they they changed the
graphs a little bit instead of a linear
graph they did a logarithmic graph to
kind of present like there was a steady
state and not a peak and a trough and
all that right in any case what happened
like any narcotic whether it's morphine
fentel Oxycontin uh vik perks it doesn't
matter they're all equ addicted you know
on a dose dependent fashion they all do
the same thing so then then the
pharmaceutical industry uh encouraged
doctors to treat pain they made pain as
a fifth Vital sign right so uh people
were taught to expect that their pain
should be more aggressively treated that
they should not feel any pain at all and
things like that right so doctors boom
they they uh flooded the market with
with this medication and then uh what
happened the government started started
realizing that a lot of people are
getting addicted so then they uh tighten
the prescribing patterns well what
happened when they tighten the
prescribing patterns people couldn't get
it for free anymore through government
uh and the and the medical industry so
they turned to the streets well that's
exactly what's happening now with
Aderall and stimulants the if you look
up dsm5 criteria for ADHD and just
reflect on your own life you will
realize that you can diagnose anyone
with ADHD and give them stimulants and
that is what is happening because if you
look at the prescribing patterns of
Aderall you will see that between uh
2010 and 2016 uh the amount of Aderall
consumed went up to two by two and a
half times and we're talking millions of
people so what's going to happen
eventually is they're going to try to uh
decrease the uh amount of you know kind
of tighten it up like the opioids and
people are going to turn to uh streets
again which they're already doing but
that's not the only thing bro you you go
back to before world uh after World War
II it was an amphetamine epidemic right
after that and right after that when the
generation realized how destructive that
is it was a uh uh narcotic epidemic
during Vietnam
War and right after that it was a crack
epidemic again a stimulant during the
90s and right after that it was again
narcotic uh crisis which we're kind of
on the tail end of in the early 2000s
and now we're ramping up a stimulant
epidemic every time a generation Los
uses the memory of the destruction that
was on the drugs they go back to it
because the shaan he's just recycling
his weapons that's all he's doing and
that's why Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he said this is filth
abomination of the devil bro and that's
how you have to see it and no matter if
it comes from a dude in a coat or a dude
in a trap house is the same
thing Subhan Allah that was that was
amazingly put together you know when you
said that the Shan just recycles his
tactics he uses very similar ways ways
to get you and trap you in different
Avenues it's the same tricks that are in
let's say strip clubs same tricks that
are in pornography same uh tricks that
are going to be on college campuses bro
and unfortunately people can't see past
it but once you recognize how to
overcome these tricks of the devil it's
almost like you begin to I guess defend
yourself from Shan in all avenues of
your life it's not just one and even in
the dsm5 Bro to go on your point about
ADHD when you look at the prevalence and
you look at actually like the
demographics right you see the
disproportion in the rates between men
and women what if it's just something
like what if Boys by Nature are just
supposed to be a little bit more
hyperactive but then it's like what
metrics are you using to decide
hyperactive and how do you know these
are deviant and not natural see there's
that's why there's a difference in
medicine with natural and normal because
they can change the definitions with
what is normal depending on the societal
climate depending on uh I guess rates of
whatever in the time science science
right findings discoveries uh how they
redefine it right subh today there's a
debate what is a woman right we don't
can't even Define that but with
something that's natural we all know
these things are natural bro it's like
when we were talking about mental health
and and phobias and you were telling me
actually bro 99% of people have
different fears that everyone else has
but it's not something abnormal it's
it's natural but they just make it seem
that way and subh when you said pain
well there so many people in my family
when we talk about pain medications you
know what they like you have a little
bit of soreness you're you're you're
feeling pain take an Advil take a tel
why like what's wrong with just feeling
that isn't it a normal inbuilt safety
mechanism from Allah to just feel these
symptoms why do we have to always hypert
treat these things you know we're not
saying to go against obviously the
advice of your medical practitioner we
don't want to get flagged for medical
misinformation but ask yourself these
things like for the last thousands of
years women have been giving birth
perfectly without taking prenatal
supplements I'm not saying to not take
that but do you really need these things
right even the things that the the
little jib Jabs that they put on our
body to fight off uh pandemics they
haven't been doing that before have they
and then when you look at just even in
recent times you know specifically in
the populations today where they think
they need these things to to get by even
caffeine unfortunately like people don't
realize you can get addicted to caffeine
you know but one of the silent Killers
you know today on unfortunately is going
to be pornography right and and people
think okay it's better than doing Zen
right because I'm not married I don't
want to you know have Zena so it's okay
if I just you know fap at home what do
you think about
that I think that's uh just lying to
yourself it's just like tasting it that
that drug uh I I think it's a it's a
delusion that a lot of people you know
look if if that is what what you're if
that's what you're looking at and I
understand look there's there's a
Temptation so the Shayan works on
Temptation there's a temptation to look
at that but if you ask yourself truly
what am I looking at uh and does
Allah like this you would first the
answer is Allah hates this you're
looking at Zenna what Allah deems as one
of the most disgusting things right uh
for what he's destroyed people for
before like the you know people with
loot right so you're looking at that
with pleasure so you love something that
hates while you you're a Muslim right
but not only that you have a delusion it
is a delusion and I I think we talked
about this already but what would happen
if you saw your own daughter your own
mother your own sister on that screen
then you would see it as Allah sees it
only then that is the truth when that is
the only time you will see truth because
uh the in the first way when it's not
your daughter when it's somebody else's
daughter when it's somebody else's
sister your desires are ruined so your
desires are or are uh it's all about
perception life is about perception it's
not about what you see it's how you
interpret it right so your desires are
are interpreting it for you as something
good where when you see it for reality
when you actually see a reality and it's
overpowers your desires then you only
see reality so I think it
is extremely harmful and not only that
it makes you perceive reality for
something that it isn't it makes you
perceive women for something that
they're not and treat women as something
that they're not and and you know it's a
movie it's uh it's it's pretend so and
you know and also I think even with
pornography uh what happens is just like
with any drug right when you first start
drugs a little bit gets you high right a
little alcohol gets you high but what do
you have to do when afterwards right you
have to increase it right so I I same
thing happens with pornography once you
get bored of the same old same old what
you do is you start sinking and further
and further deviant
looking for things that will provide the
same type of entertainment for you as
they did before cuz you ain't trying to
rewatch everything for the rest of your
life people go more and more deviant and
and I mean some people end up with like
super gross stuff yeah man and like
that's that's it's a slippery slope
right you can't keep watching the same
vanilla every single day over time
you're going to start going into you
know same sex a lot of whether it's
watching women or men it's still
corruption your F in your mind and your
soul
and then over time it's going to go to
what bity and then CP and when it's CP
you can't people go on the dark web for
that stuff and it's do you realize like
your threshold for arousal is just being
artificially you know adjusted day by
day fat by fap for what nothing and then
when you have a real woman in halal and
you get married to her you can't get it
up and you're wondering why and she's
getting in Secure she's getting put off
it has nothing to do with her it has
everything to do with your addiction
obviously this not a a gendered issue we
have sisters Unfortunately today they're
getting caught up in this too uh but by
and large majority of women you know
even the ones that unfortunately are uh
you know getting caught up in this
addiction usually you know from what I
know they do you know romance novels and
stuff like that they're not really
visual as much although there are many
women now but mainly it's it's an issue
affecting men and not to mention bro
this affects your testosterone levels
this affects your mental Clarity and
just anytime you disobey Allah even as a
non-muslim because you know Allah so
created every single human being right
in all creation even as a non-muslim bro
you still feel that dissonance you still
feel that that sting of disobeying Allah
because even the the non-muslims the
kuar they have postal Clarity and they
still feel some type of way bro after
they they do this they feel as shame
they feel guilt and in the Western
School System you know what they tell
you I spoke about this in my own channel
in VI fit that the Western school system
today they will tell you it's actually
normal and not only that it's healthy
for you to pleasure yourself
it's unhealthy if you don't you know it
clears the pipes keeps everything in
check like no bro having intimacy with
your wife is normal that's it everything
else is just deviant it's unnecessary an
Islamic point of view you shouldn't do
it but from just a normal masculinity
point of view it's robbing your Sexual
Energy bro and we wonder why people
don't have energy nowadays you know but
going into a little bit more about these
these uh addictions where do you think
the first place that men can look for to
I guess turn their life around make that
180 uh Allah and when I say that I mean
Salah you know uh if you
are doing any drugs right uh if you are
an addict and you see yourself as a
Muslim uh you know Allah defines Muslims
as those people who pray it's just just
no way around it you know I mean if you
you know if you read the Quran you will
see that one of the mark of Hypocrites
of monics is they pray to be seen of
people so even the mafics prayed in in
his time right uh so we have Muslims now
who don't even pray so that's number one
and and so you got to understand why
addiction and and Salah are the sides
two sides of the same coin they are
diametrically opposed you get you get to
choose one you can't choose both so
Allah says in the Quran
uh this is in the 29th chapter of the
verse 45 andite that which has been
revealed to you from your lord and keep
up prayer keep up Salah surely Salah
keeps away from indecency and evil and
remembrance of God is e right and if we
go back to the fifth chapter Quran verse
91 is what is the purpose of what is the
purpose to make you to forget forget
about Allah right and then in the fourth
chapter of Quran I think it's Surah 43
Ayah 43 it says all you who believe do
not approach Salah do not approach
prayer while you are intoxicated until
until you know what you are saying now
we talked about that 40-day or Salah
won't be accepted all day that doesn't
matter what it matters is that this is a
weapon for you whether it's accepted or
not you still are clean and you still so
all you got to do as a Muslim if you are
an addict to be a Muslim if you see
yourself as a Muslim you have to realize
that prayer defines you and once you
realize that prayer Salah defines you
you keep up every single Salah guess
what even if you can't quit even if you
after Isa if you get high what happened
to you 95% of your problems are gone bro
like think about it if you a crackhead
on the streets just smoking rocks 24
hours a day you hide 24 hours a day is
just destroyed your life well now you're
sober throughout the day so you it's not
you're not perfect but you took the
first step and now your life is no
longer a disaster I I you you're going
from a highway car crash to a fender
bender there even even in the modern in
the medical sense when we're talking
about uh addiction medicine we realize
that uh complete abstinence is much
harder to achieve than risk reduction
harm reduction and there is no greater
harm reduction just if you claim to be a
Muslim your harm reduction is Salah
exactly what it says you know Salah
keeps away from indecency and evil it
helps you it saves you and I mean this
there is to it and there's nothing else
to it again if you're not going to on
Allah you can try everything else but
success rates in addiction recovery are
are are terrible and guess what else
while you are in recovery and once you
become an addict you're always in
recovery you're never not an addict once
an addict always an addict you can be a
recovery for the rest of your life but
without Salah you are one catastrophe
away from turning back to your crutch to
your coping mechanism what was your
coping mechanism the drug M your family
dies your daughter dies your son dies
right you lose your house something
happens you're super
depressed boom I mean and you can you
can imagine that for
yourself I think most people in the
western world have tried to keep some
sort of a diet right sometimes at one
point in their life they wanted to work
out and they wanted to keep a diet and
what is the greatest issue when people
try to keep a diet depression you know
and that I don't care feeling right when
that hits you if you have ever been an
addict when that I don't care feeling
hits you due to a
tragedy boom and guess what
else when your drug is freely
available the hardest thing to quit in
the Western World world is alcohol cuz
there's no barriers if I want to relapse
I just go to the bar or I just go to the
store and I buy now I can do the same
thing with weed right so whereas I had
to go to the you know go to a trap house
that I haven't been through in years and
try to find the source of that which may
help me get through that uh day now I
don't have that anymore I don't even
have that protection anymore so when
they talking about legalizing drugs I
think they forget about this issue of
recovery CU When you are surrounded by
the drug and you feel bad and you all
you have to do is walk to the store it's
done bro that was I never thought of it
that way the the barrier of Entry now to
accessibility is the doesn't even exist
bro you you don't like even in a student
house you're not going out there
somebody in your in the house is doing
something and someone has something
right in the off campus housing uh
whether you look at you know Walmart you
know I'm from Canada so when I moved to
America recently I saw that you know I
went to Walmart and they just have Al we
didn't we didn't have alcohol in Walmart
bro it's very controlled and a little
bit more different than here gas
stations you name it everyone just
selling alcohol I was just like what is
this and you can just buy it accessibly
sure you need to ID but now you got the
fake ID if there's a will there's a way
right so there's always going to be fake
IDs there's always going to be people
trying to pull strings and if we look at
the problem from this level we are
merely doing symptom management and we
have to reverse engineer how the Salah
itself is the first step to pioneering
change and pioneering a better life not
you know falling victim to Shan Shan
telling us always how are you going to
pray are you a mfic are you a hypocrite
you can't pray good Muslim doesn't pray
and and smoke and drink and commit Zena
doesn't matter that's just the trick of
Shan to keep you where you're at I would
rather you take baby steps obviously
knowing what Allah expects but still I
would expect I would rather somebody
takes baby steps towards Allah leaves
these things never lets go of their
Salah holds on to the Rope of Allah even
if they're sinning because they'll
eventually give up the sin and come
properly to Allah and fully submit then
somebody kind of goes you know tent to
in cold turkey quits everything and then
relaps and then never comes back to
Allah because what is the greater harm
you know we're all on that straight path
we're all on that Journey the the main
point is can you get on that Journey or
are you going to be essentially uh
letting shaan play these tricks on you
because Shan's not going to stop at you
when you get on the straight path either
bro just like you said you know we're
all addicts for life after a certain
point don't think it gets any easier bro
and many times I can even argue that
Shan's not going to come for you if
you're down bad because you know you're
already off the straight path but when
you have more to lose when you're you
know you're trying to better your life
then you might be wondering okay why
Shan coming after me it's why wouldn't
he you're going to be tested again and
these tests they'll come until the day
we die that's the purpose of this life
you know fortunately for us as Muslims
but they'll look at as unfortunately um
would you have a message though for the
non-muslims right now because many of
them are like what is Salah what is
prayer what is even Islam like I'm just
you know I'm born into Christianity my
parents are Christians why why would I
be
Muslim well I mean I I I would say the
same thing to people who claim to be
Muslims as I would uh say to those who
aren't look you can't and I I I think I
always like to uh speak to people who
are Muslims like you know because you
have people who you said are or aren't
are okay because you know when I became
a Muslim when I reverted to Islam I did
so because I read the Quran and I was
like this is what I actually always
wanted to be
but I was afraid cuz cuz you know you
know you try to be humble out here and
and if you're around the wrong people
they take it a wrong way and they try
you know they they think you're weak you
know so if you you know so I think a lot
of times all of us have in our hearts
the desire to be Muslim we don't know
what that is but the desire to you know
with the few exception of few truly evil
people the desire to just be cool with
people the desire to be kind to people
the desire to help people I think that
that is actually inborn for most people
and when you when you grow up was like I
grew up in a bad neighborhood and you
know crime was the thing and you had to
have this gangster Persona and all that
stuff you know so so people don't mess
with you uh but that's cowardice right
you thought you were being brave but
it's actually cardice because what you
really wanted to be ultimately is a
Muslim but that being
said when people tell me that they are
Muslims and they've never read the Quran
I always ask them how can you love a
book that you never read that's just the
same thing as hating a book you never
read cuz if you if you were if you were
uh grow if you grew up and and and you
were told that you are a Muslim that's
cool that's awesome you got a leg up to
everybody else right you it's for you
life is better cuz somebody you know is
picking you up it's just like somebody
trying to get helping you get into a
medical school right so that's that's a
benefit you should cash in on but when
you say that and then you say you have a
message from Allah you have hudah right
you have guidance from Allah and then
you don't want to bother to read it how
you guide it it's like you're shooting
yourself in the foot bro you know that
that that's the issue and I just want to
say Muslims like don't shoot yourself in
the foot this is what is telling you
where the dangers lie you're walking
through a Minefield you have a map where
the minds are maybe you should use it
you know all that is a Minefield right
yeah it's like everything that is Haram
is a mindfield and you just got to open
your eyes or you know Allah says uh in
the Quran you know warning about drugs
it's like just go to any downtown and
you will see all of it is exactly the
same thing man so that that's one thing
and and people who uh people who aren't
Muslims what I was Al I will say exactly
the same thing to you don't hate a book
you never read first you got to read it
if you want to hate it after that that's
fine but what I did is I would read
things out of Contex context with the
desire to to be right you so when you
sit down and you read this you got you
got to turn that off right you you that
that desire to be right that you got to
turn and just read it with an open mind
and just think about it is this telling
me to do the right thing or the wrong
thing is it will this help me or not and
and I also would like to tell people to
realize look you don't know what you
don't know and life is about experience
is you only truly understand things when
you experience them so pain you will
only truly uh understand it when you
experience it uh that's why we go to
residency in medical school so we can
actually practice and experience things
so we you know understand that so when
you read these things in the Quran you
got to realize that you're just a kid
even if you're 40 50 years old you're
just a kid and and what Allah is telling
you is for your own protection because
all this stuff leads to slavery and if
you look at your own kids if you got
kids you tell kids don't run after the
uh ball into the busy street right and
and don't get get into the van with a
man with a candy and the kid's like why
don't you want me to get some candy bro
or or I I just want the ball but you
know the consequences the kid doesn't
and the kid can get to know the
consequences the hard way by getting hit
by a car or or getting Ed right they you
you'll get to know that you can either
listen to advice or get to know the
consequences I was too stupid to listen
to
advice I got to experience the
consequences but
Allah had mercy on me but did not have
mercy most of my
friends there was deaths deportations
prison all that just
because I am relatively successful in
the world of this D I am only successful
because of the mercy of Allah because I
tried really hard to destroy my life and
and it's a miracle I I shouldn't be here
where I'm
at sub Allah and and sometimes when
things are good we forget the days where
we were begging to just help us out of
the gutters bro and we forget that you
know the life that we have now not only
is it something we be rful for back then
we would think is even unachievable
right we give an arm and a leg to have a
day in our shoes right now but now we
become heedless and ungrateful we think
we're entitled this is just how life is
so I think that another element is in
gratitude I think that Shan wants to
keep us ungrateful to Allah and about
all the blessings that we've been given
so many times we feel in general too bro
I think men have become just softer yeah
there's this societal element like you
mentioned in big fora and Shan so we're
all victims to an extent but even on
that day Shan's going to say I had
nothing to do with you I merely just
give you a whisper any evil you commit
is by your own two hands so at the end
of the day why are we so soft in coping
with hardships bro life is supposed to
be difficult we're supposed to be
stressed any time you feel like you know
you're overwhelmed then you need to sip
or you need to smoke something why like
like ask yourself that like do we can we
really just not cope anymore are we just
that dependent on crutches and things to
get us through the day obviously there's
a difference between caffeine and you
know getting that stuff done getting a
boost in the day but I'm talking about
these these intoxicants the the you know
as Allah says in the Quran uh but before
we end this there is one last question
for you uh where can people find you at
where if they want to watch some of your
Tik toks and videos where can they find
you uh on Tik Tok
uh I'm under the handle American Muslim
uh on on YouTube uh it's SI D oom which
is like a old bosan movie uh that I used
to watch it is orphanage so it's uh
basically means great home in bosan uh
and I don't I don't uh use IG that much
but uh what I was going to I wanted to
say one more thing of course
uh no I forgot what I was going to
say in this gives us an excuse for part
two with Dennis inah uh but if you do
remember do I don't remember I don't
remember what I was going to say but I I
do want to close with this obey Allah
and Obey a messeng obey the messenger
but be warned if you turn away then on
the messenger was only clearly
deliver sub Allah all right guys smash
that like button inshallah links in the
description to find Dr Dennis you know
go click those links hit them up on Tik
Tok YouTube and inshallah we'll see you
guys in the next one keep us in your
daas may Allah subh protect us from the
shatan and the tricks of the devil those
that you know greatest trick of the
devil is to convince the world that he
doesn't exist soan is real you know and
he's coming for us so whether you
protect yourself or not don't think that
your kids AR going to be affected your
wife isn't going to be affected you know
Shan's going to have us by the grips if
we don't build that Fortress of
ourselves and protect us inshah I do
remember what I was going to say perfect
yeah so uh what I was going to say when
you Sayan this is what I was going to
say is look uh Shayan was ordered to bow
down to us so whenever we bow down to
him and follow him we're serving an
entity that is lower than ourselves we
are lowering
ourselves you know so I just said a
paradigm sh bro you're right Subhan
Allah and you know shortly after that I
believe the Mal the Angels asked Allah
why are you creating a human
civilization knowing what came before
them right and Allah says I know what
you know not well when they're going to
shed uh yeah I remember that Ayah it
says why are you uh basically creating
them knowing that they're going to shed
blood in yeah in the word and says I
know what you don't know so trust
Allah we we
get we can change the world by changing
ourselves whoever decides to become a
Muslim actually live out the Quran to
the best of their ability you're not
going to be perfect but if you do you've
changed the world for your parents
you've changed the world for your
community you changed the the world
world to who for whoever interacts with
you you changed the world bro I was
terrible to my my mom and when I became
a
Muslim I'm sure her world got better I
changed the world I maybe just changed
it a little bit but I did change it you
know so people want to change the world
well there you go if you want to change
the world for the better do what the
Quran says just the verses you can start
the verses that are right what Allah say
says in the in the third chapter of
Quran verse 7 in it there are verses
that are they are the mother of the book
they are the Bas that they are what is
important uh in the book just read what
is easy of the Quran whatever you
recognize it's easy to understand like
like that one my favorite vers is uh and
your lord uh and it say it
says that we are all you who believe why
do you say that which you do not do most
hateful to Allah most hateful to Allah
is that you should say that which you
did not do Super E you don't need you
don't you don't need a scholar to tell
you that do that see how easy to do that
if you do that your life is going to
change and you are going to be of
exalted moral character just by one
thing subh
subh bro so simple just integrity and
just following through right so
beautiful uh point to end it on bro I
never thought about the Bowing down toas
like that Subhan Allah with this being
said guys comment down below your
thoughts inshallah we'll get brother
Dennis back on the Pod very soon and
keep us in we need
it